[Music]
last Tuesday marked the premiere of a
show called America's greatest makers
which airs right here on TBS it's pretty
cool idea the show makes twenty four
teams of makers and puts them in
head-to-head competition and the winner
goes home with 1 million dollars
I guess they come up with different
ideas and schemes and execute them
here's a clip war dream phones actively
improve the quality of your sleep each
night this is the cat clutch it's an
illuminated handbag you can customize
with your phone a smart low-cost
wristband that motivates stroke patients
to do their rehabilitation exercises and
speed up their recovery we're aiming to
provide a solution to the complex
interactions of law enforcement and
American citizens
there's a need for this in the
marketplace alright new episodes of
America's greatest makers err Tuesday's
on TBS the entire thing is brought to
you by Intel so be sure to check it out
you